5  55 on your wednesday morning how about  putting the overnight brakes on your jam  from the spaghetti bowl to the rainbow  curve  last night the nevada department of  transportation started a six-week  closure of the left shoulder  and the hov lane north 95 rancho  all the way around the rainbow curve up  to washington this is going to run  mondays through  fridays from 8 in the evening until 6 in  the morning until  june the 30th even though there's  usually not a whole lot of traffic there  during those hours the work being done  could for sure be a distraction they're  changing all those super tall lights in  that stretch to more energy efficient  leds  buckle up drive carefully please put  down that phone if there is something  driving you crazy please email me  traffic eight  at eight news now dot com